bonsoir banques les ont merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
la plus haute juridiction de l'onu se
disent compétentes
est ce une véritable avancée pour l'iran
aujourd'hui
oui bien sûr d'abord parce que ça
rappelle tout simplement que les états
unis ont conclu un accord d'amitié et de
coopération commerciale avec l'iran en
1955 à l'époque du shah et que soit il
avait oublié l'existence de cet accord
soit ils pensaient qu'il ne produirait
plus d'effet puisqu'il n'y a plus de
relations diplomatiques entre l'iran les
états unis depuis 40 ans toujours est il
que ils ne l'ont dénoncé qu'après que
l'iran est introduit et une action
devant la cour internationale de justice
en 2018 après l'imposition des sanctions
par les états unis
et c'est à dire trop tard donc ils se
sont retirés de cet accord trop tard et
c'est dans cette logique que la cour
internationale de justice aujourd'hui se
reconnaît compétente pour juger au fond
et donc ceci est évidemment exposé les
états unis à déconvenue importante car
si la procédure continue de se dérouler
et bien il y aurait d'ici quelques mois
plus vraisemblablement d'ici quelques
années un jugement au fond de la cour
internationale de justice pour peut-être
dire que ces sanctions n'étaient pas
justifiées elle a d'ailleurs déjà fait
en partie en urgence à la demande de
l'iran juste après l'introduction de la
requête de léran en 2018
la cour internationale de justice a pris
une première décision au nom de
l'urgence humanitaire qui rend joignait
aux etats-unis dans de retirer toute
restrictions au commerce des produits
pharmaceutiques des équipements médicaux
des produits alimentaires des produits
agricoles et aussi de tous les produits
et services qui permettent de faire
fonctionner via son civile donc cela
évidemment a mis la puce à l'oreille aux
états unis
qui ont compris que la cour s'estimer
compétentes et que un jour elle pour en
venir à faire un jugement au fond mais
d'ici là il est probable que les états
unis ont retrouvé les voies et moyens de
rentrer dans l'accord du 14 juillet 2015
et qu' ils n'auront pas à attendre sept
7 cet avis prendre cet avis cet arrêt de
la cour sur le fond alors l'union
européenne dit travailler dur pour faire
lever les sanctions américaines l'iran
elle en appelle justement a lieu alors
l'europe peut-elle s'imposer en tant que
médiateur dans cette affaire oui tout à
l'heure vous avez cité les paroles du
ministre des affaires étrangères iranien
qui en effet lance un appel très directe
à josep borrell le haut représentant de
l'union européenne pour les affaires
étrangères et la sécurité en lui disant
qu'il pourrait jouer le rôle de
coordonnateur de l'exécution de l'accord
de juillet 2015 et qu' il pourrait
organiser ce qu'il a appelé d'un beau
terme perçant la chorégraphie de la
rentrée des etats-unis dans cet accord
avec en même temps la reprise des
obligations départ les iraniens puisque
naturellement de l'administration
américaine prouve un préalable c'est que
avant de rentrer dans l'accord elle veut
que les iraniens respecte l'intégralité
de leurs obligations
or ils se sont écartés sur certains
points de ses obligations risquées donc
une coordination à organiser et l'union
européenne pourraient s'y prêter je ne
suis pas sûr que les états unis laisse
faire monsieur borrèze tout seul puisque
après tout le président joe biden à
désigner un envoyé spécial pour l'iran
que cet envoyé spécial pour l'iran est
un diplomate très chevronnés qui
d'ailleurs été un des artisans de
l'accord du 14 juillet 2015 et qui
voudra sans doute joué un rôle central
il pas exclu non plus que les mises
affaires étrangères
allemands français britanniques et
d'autres peut-être qu'ils ont signé cet
accord veille aussi joué un rôle
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est que chacun
rajoute des conditions et rendre la
fameuse chorégraphie mentionné par le
ministre iranien des affaires étrangères
impossible à exécuter alors pour la
république islamique d'iran si l'étau ne
se desserrera pas quelles conséquences
politiques
c'est très simple l'iran à des élections
présidentielles le 18 juin prochain
c'était date après tout pourquoi pas le
18 juin en iran aussi et que évidemment
les conservateurs les plus les plus
réactionnaires j'allais dire ont le vent
en poupe puisque dans le fond le
marchandage sur lequel reposaient cet
accord n'a pas fonctionné les américains
sont se retirer il ya toujours des
sanctions et les sanctions américaines
sont très lourde puisque les américains
peuvent ou ne veulent pas qu'elles
soient contournées par les européens et
menace les entreprises européennes qui
seraient des affaires en iran ou qu'ils
utiliseraient le dollar de sanctions sur
le marché américain ou de sanction pour
avoir utilisé le dollar dans ce pays par
conséquent il ya là un problème très
important est évidemment l'iran est
actuellement dans une situation
économique
tout à fait mauvaise d'ailleurs le
gouvernement iranien a dit que les
sanctions américaines était fait pour
détruire l'économie iranienne pour tuer
des millions d'iraniens et il est
vraisemblable que monsieur ben laden n'a
pas beaucoup de temps pour organiser la
rentrée des états unis en cet accord et
par conséquent le retour des iraniens à
l'exécution de leur engagement plein
dans cet accord si tel ou tel veut
ajouter d'autres conditions ou d'autres
indices à cet accord il est probable que
l'ensemble
évidemment aboutir à un échec merci
claude blanche maison